well let's return now to uh that
announcement within the last few minutes
that the former Chancellor Sajid Javid
has said that he will not stand at the
next general election Let's uh bring in
Amanda acass who is in Westminster for
us
um morning Amanda and there's been a
trickle haven't there of MPS saying that
they don't intend to stand again at the
next general election this is probably
the highest profile
yes absolutely I mean Sajid Javid has
been an extremely high profile
politician within the conservative party
he was home secretary Chancellor Health
secretary and he himself has stood for
leader of the party
um on two occasions neither of them
successful the first time against Boris
Johnson in which he came fourth and
Boris Johnson then appointed him as
Chancellor but he ended up resigning
over a row
um over his advisors with Dominic
Cummings and Boris Johnson later he was
then reappointed Health secretary and it
was his decision to resign from Boris
Johnson's government last summer along
with on the same day Rishi sunak
following the scandals over partygate
and the Rouse
um the various scandals that affected
Boris Johnson's Administration that
really precipitated his downfall
um then satajaved himself was going to
stand again to be leader of the party
this summer but he ended up withdrawing
from contest before he had actually been
nominated he then supported Liz truss
obviously we all know what happened to
her he then had switched his and agents
to Rishi sunak and did back him as
leader but I think that kind of Fairly
bumpy career history that I've just
outlined perhaps suggests why he's
decided that now is the time for him to
stand down although I think compared to
the other MPS who've made that decision
he's not someone who represents a
marginal constituency bromsgrove near
Birmingham he has a majority of 23 000
so even if there's a massive swing
towards labor if the polls are to be
believed at the next general election
then he's not someone who's likely to
face the humiliation of leaving of
losing his seat in his letter itself he
he says it's a decision that he's
wrestled with for some time but
ultimately concluded not to stand again
because conservative MPS have been told
they've got to make a decision about
whether or not they're going to stand by
the 5th of December he's this is very
proud of what he's achieved
and being the local MP and serving in
government has been the privilege of my
life I'm immensely grateful for the
opportunity to serve I always sought to
make decisions in the National interest
and in line with my values and I can
only hope my best was sufficient now he
says he'll continue to support his
friend the Prime Minister and the people
of his constituency in any way he can
having said that there's no criticism of
the Prime Minister of the decisions made
by him and the chancellor in the Autumn
statement to raise taxes and make those
spending cuts which have been
controversial with Tory MPS but I think
this is yet another blow for the Prime
Minister on a day in which he's just
seen the loss of a by-election as well